it's four days after the biggest
earthquake here in a century and where
the first foreign journalist inside
idlib to see the devastation
they know all about Misery here they've
endured nearly 12 years of war now
they're fighting to survive a natural
disaster and they're doing it in the
awful realization that once again
they're on their own
so they dig through the night the white
helmets so used to pulling people out of
bombed buildings now trying to sift
through Rubble to find those who
survived the war only to die trapped and
terrified in the earthquake
they've just found the body of a
four-year-old boy still in his pajamas
his father can hardly contain his
Despair and disgust at how he was left
to die alone with no help from outside
who's helping us in Turkey they're
getting everything they've arranged
special flights to bring Aid in from all
over the world but no one has come to
help us what did this child do wrong to
stay four days under the rubble before
we found him
and the agony is not over yet for him
white helmets are trying to find his
wife and his Elder son who's 10 both are
still missing the people here are saying
this is a real tragedy because it could
have been all so different if they'd
been given extra Specialists more
sophisticated equipment with which to
try and locate these people remember
some have already been taken out of here
alive but now the chances of finding
anyone else alive are extremely remote
have you found anything no is the
constant answer even finding the body of
a loved one is some small comfort in
this part of Syria where Comfort is a
scarcity
the northwest of Syria is a rebel
Enclave packed with about 4 million
people who fled Bashar al-assad and his
regime in Damascus
the head of the militant islamist Group
which controls the area turned up to
give us a rare interview and he was
blisteringly critical of the world's
response
they're taking too much time and it's
costing the lives of those trapped under
the rubble a lot of people are dying
because of the weak response of the
International Community they're the ones
responsible for all these deaths
he was once a member of the terror group
Al-Qaeda before forming his own
Breakaway Group which he says is now
focused on fighting AQ as well as Isis
and the Assad regime in the Syrian
capital
he has a 10 million dollar bounty on his
head but he tore into Western leaders
for ignoring the needs of civilians in
idlib
the people who died in the earthquake
were not terrorists they were innocent
civilians there were women and children
so to confuse humanitarian issues with
politics is a big problem
in the first week after the earthquake
we find only bodies coming over the
Turkish Syrian Border in any quantity
little meaningful Aid has made it across
these are people who have fled the war
in Syria to find sanctuary in
neighboring turkey now being returned in
body bags it is the saddest of
homecomings for their relatives
so they're having to make Mass graves in
idlib to cope with the hundreds coming
home from across the border as well as
those who've perished here they simply
can't make them quickly enough
they were already struggling with the
impact of an unequal War now more
unbearable loss
a final kiss for a newborn baby a life
cut off before it had even really begun
this is a tragedy on top of a grinding
war and earthquake Calamity they're
talking here of deaths after the Quakes
caused by poor medical facilities of the
struggle without shelter of the need for
food and water of the urgency for just
about everything
so there is misery upon misery and the
News no one wanted
Saleem found his wife and Son's bodies
and with that Discovery a whole new
depth to his suffering he's now lost
half of his family two sons and their
mothers
for a child in idlib there seems no end
to grief life for them is all about
death
Saleem has to somehow console his one
surviving daughter eight-year-old mace
calm down my daughter he says okay my
love
this is God's will yeah
do you love me
I'll always be with you he says
they have each other but that is all
the trauma in idlib never seems to stop
it just gets worse and worse
[Music]
and two weeks on from the first there's
more terror with a second set of
earthquakes
return to find people really struggling
and anger building
Aid is still only trickling into
Northwest Syria and people are digging
through their ruined homes for scraps of
their possessions
the un's already admitted it failed to
mobilize help quickly enough but on the
ground we find little evidence this has
morphed into any visible support
yet there are stunning Tales of
endurance and courage of Rescuers who
refuse to give up
this was once four apartment blocks
unrecognizable now
there were concrete slabs one on top of
each other he tells us up to a hundred
were dead inside but remarkably at least
one teenager called Rima was still alive
the white helmets volunteers and
dreamers relatives were working with
very little no heavy machinery at all at
this point just their bare hands and a
lot of ingenuity
they managed to squeeze their way
through the gaps following the sound of
her screams until they found her cold
and terrified and with her right leg
pinned down by tons of concrete
the only way to free her was to amputate
her leg there under the rubble
yeah level four
she can't remember much of her ordeal
just her desperation to get out
when I was trapped in the hole there was
a dead man next to me she goes on I was
really afraid I just wanted to get out
Rima like other survivors are finding
living with the aftermath as a further
Herculean Challenge and all we spoke to
are bitter at how they've been left to
this fate
what did the Syrian people do wrong what
is our sin that the world left us like
this are our lives worth nothing why
we're human beings we respect humanity
and respect human rights we're we're not
barbarians
why were you so late it reads we were
waiting for you they will remember those
who helped the people here and those who
didn't long after the rubble has been
pieced back together again
the hospitals are packed with children
like Iceland Lorna how are you he says
my love
open your eyes for me
it means lion and he's living up to his
name
he is the sole survivor in his family
both his parents and his two older
siblings died in the earthquakes
his uncle is now his guardian and is
willing him to be strong
but his body has taken a battering he
has terrible Crush injuries to his legs
and the doctor says he may need both
amputated he'll certainly never be the
same again the fact he's here at all is
a miracle
we make no apologies for this video
being upsetting it is gruesome but this
is the reality the bodies of aslan's
siblings had already been found by this
point
but this is arsalan's Father Suleiman
his dying Act was to use his body to
Shield his youngest child
as he's pulled out you can see arsalan's
arm poking through the stones he's
wearing striped pajamas
he's the last to be recovered they hope
against hope he's alive
then as he's dragged out of the rubble
they realize he is
his eyes flicker open unbelievably he's
made it
he is alive only because of his father's
love but it's just one of many battles
ahead for the toddler
and the Medics insists the delay by the
U.N in sending Aid is responsible for
his suffering feet why yes don't give
them the
care that they need
is this
people or this children is responsible
about the Assad Andrew border and
International Community can he
understand
he lost his
single one of his family
he
don't know anything about this and they
don't care about this and I'll just
forget about this I want this patient to
survive and as well as the injured there
are the earthquake babies born
prematurely as their terrified mothers
scrambled to safety
Fatima weighs a kilo the feeding syringe
next to her is almost as big as she is
every movement she makes however small
is welcomed by the nurses it shows a
fighting Spirit she will need to survive
being born in the midst of an earthquake
and in a country at War
the number of babies like Fatima
violently arriving early into the world
because of the earthquakes has jumped by
50 according to the doctors here
and with four ventilators being shared
amongst about 20 little ones the chances
are many of these babies will not
survive to see life outside these wards
do you think you can save any of them or
is it just too difficult right now
they'll try our best to save all of them
but right now the border gate to Turkey
is closed and it won't be enough to
depend on just the equipment we have
here
many are too scared to stay inside their
homes and even hospital patients
including children are still so fearful
of more Tremors and aftershocks they
prefer to sleep outside
visiting Canadian doctors also joined
the chorus criticizing the UN saying it
was responsible for many lives lost
this is because of the latest Forest
if the response was early we could have
saved many lives this is simple you
don't I think you understand that you
don't have to be physician or surgeon to
understand that a crush injury if you
wait four or five days the outcome is
going to be very bad
and even those with Lion Hearts haven't
been able to defy the politicking a few
hours after we left idlib arceland the
little boy who survived the war and then
the earthquake lost his fight for Life
killed by what the doctors believe were
bureaucratic battles
Alex Crawford Sky News in idlib
Northwest Syria